[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a family comedy film called
thunderpants spoilers ahead watch out
and take
[Music]
care in the opening scene the smash
family is in a hospital room waiting to
welcome the newest member of their
family mrs smash struggles to give birth
but after a strong push the baby flies
out of her it does several flips mid-air
and has a full head of hair thankfully
the doctor catches him and hands him
back to the family they name the baby
boy patrick while trying to take a
family picture patrick farts for the
first time following that it never stops
the parents can hardly sleep at night
because of all the fart noises patrick's
strange condition would have been
tolerable to his parents if it weren't
for the foul smell one time mr smash
goes to tend to the infant in the middle
of the night and has to retreat because
of the pungent smell patrick won't sleep
the entire night and just keeps passing
gas when it is time for a change mr
smash comes up with an innovative idea
he ties a plastic garbage bag around
patrick's waist so the noise would be
suppressed and the smell wouldn't spread
around the room however the bag gets so
big that it explodes with a loud bang
waking the entire neighborhood as
patrick grows up into a toddler mr smash
gets more creative he attaches patrick's
behind to one end of a pipe that way his
farts are transported outside but the
kid moves so much that the pipe detaches
from the other end one time the pipe
lands right before mr smash's face and
the fart hospitalizes him following the
event he keeps himself busy with work
and hardly ever stays at home until
eventually he abandons the family and
leaves them forever
patrick's older sister denise starts
hating him for destroying her perfect
little family even mrs smash blames him
for the trouble patrick is nervous and
excited for his first day of school he
tries to fit in like everyone else but
he has to let out a fart only a few
minutes in the kids retreat away from
him and laugh except a boy named alan
who is kind to patrick allen has a
condition called enosmia and thus lacks
the sense of smell the two become best
friends and do everything together
patrick's life doesn't get easier even
after getting a friend he is constantly
bullied by a guy named damon at his
school during the morning assembly the
kids are asked to keep quiet for a
special guest speech everyone does is
told but patrick lets out a loud and
pungent fart which gets him suspended
for a few days patrick wants to become
an astronaut when he grows up but he
doesn't know if that is possible because
of his problem astronauts are patient
people but if patrick dutch ovened a
whole rocket ship it wouldn't end well
he frequently watches shows about space
and astronomy and is left disheartened
when his favorite astronaut says that an
astronaut should have complete control
of himself allen on the other hand wants
to be a scientist and invent a flying
machine that doesn't use fuel patrick
asks for his help to create a device
that will suppress his farts alan takes
on the challenge and spends hours in his
backyard lab to create a fart collecting
and suppressing device called the
thunderpants while patrick is waiting
for his friend outside the lab someone
takes a picture of him without him
knowing after getting done allen makes
patrick wear the device that collects
his farts in a box with the press of a
button following that the box is
supposed to be kept in a stabilizer that
suppresses the fart smell and disposes
of it patrick is beyond thankful to his
friend now that he has solved the
biggest problem in his life before this
he was only allowed to eat whole grain
food so he walks up to his sister and
eats a spoonful of beans from her plate
denise is left speechless because she is
used to mocking him for not being able
to eat tasty food like her imagine
feeling left out because you can't eat
beans weird the following day at school
everyone is asked to stay silent in the
morning assembly the thunder pants work
and no one hears patrick farting during
the lunch break he asks alan to help him
find his unique talent because his
favorite astronaut general ed shepherd
said on a tv show that all astronauts
have one alan bluntly tells his friend
that he has no unique talent completely
overlooking his ability to fart as they
talk the bully damon asks for patrick's
lunchbox and snatches his fart
collecting box instead when he opens it
he is blasted with a pungent smell and a
green powder on his face he gets so mad
at patrick for setting up the prank that
he ties him to the monkey bars as
punishment the bully and his friends
tear open the thunder pants and beat him
up they have to retreat when he lets out
a smelly fart yet again everyone calls
him a fart boy and makes fun of him
while poor patrick stands humiliated the
next day he doesn't go to school still
traumatized by the event in the evening
allen comes to visit him with a better
thunder pants to replace the one that
was destroyed however patrick has lost
the will to suppress his farts because
his dream to become an astronaut isn't
going to come true anyway
alan realistically tells him to become
an astronaut one should be at his
physical peak and has to pass several
exams patrick is far from healthy and is
not smart enough to pass them allen
apologizes for being so blunt but
patrick walks away knowing that he is
telling the truth when alan returns home
two men outside patrick's house keep an
eye on him we see that they have several
pictures of both alan and patrick almost
as if they have been spying on them
that week miss smash brings patrick to
the hospital to get his condition
checked professionally the doctor is
shocked to see that the kid has two
stomachs he calls patrick medical magic
but also calls his ability a completely
useless gift patrick is overjoyed
because having two stomachs means that
he has a unique quality which he thinks
makes him eligible to become an
astronaut meanwhile allen is planning to
participate in an invention competition
where he has to create a vehicle that
will fly a hundred meters without using
fuel after finding out that his friend
has two stomachs he plans to use
patrick's farting abilities to win the
competition on the day of the
competition they go against many
participants but none of their devices
are able to move to the threshold
distance some devices fall apart while
others do not start at all when it is
alan's turn they use patrick's farts to
make a device fly in the air the
audience is left stunned in the first
half but soon the device malfunctions
and the fart is blown towards them alan
quickly repairs it and wins the
competition following the win patrick
gets enough courage to stand up to damon
he follows him to a forest and farts in
his face making him fall unconscious as
patrick is smugly returning home that
day he sees alan get into a black car
with a suitcase on asking alan's father
about his whereabouts he is given a
letter in it alan wishes him luck for
his dream and says that he will be away
for a long time his father claims he has
moved to a different country and will
not be back soon without his best friend
patrick doesn't know what to do he
returns home and watches the news about
a group of astronauts being stranded in
space astronaut ed shepherd says that
the team needs a miracle to be brought
back to the earth safely later the opera
singer sir john osgood approaches
patrick to help him in his next
performance jon had seen patrick in the
competition and believes that his fart
has the perfect pitch that he needs at
the end of his song when jon promises to
take him to a different country patrick
agrees to go hoping that he would find
his best friend first they travel to
paris to perform in front of an audience
consisting of world famous opera singers
at the end of the song patrick farts
helping jon reach a perfect pitch jon
gets a standing ovation from the
audience who are unaware that patrick
was helping them following the show john
is noted as the best opera singer in the
world much to his competitor placido p
placido's annoyance john and patrick
travel all over europe singing in
various shows
with every show john's popularity
increases however he urges patrick to
practice farting every day for hours
letting him eat only after he hits the
correct notes one day while he is
practicing he is visited by placito who
finds out about john's little secret he
then mixes a laxative on a pie and feeds
it to patrick hoping to ruin jon's next
performance a few hours later john is
singing in one of his shows as usual
patrick hits the highest notes with his
farts and even breaks wine glasses with
the noise the spotlight right above the
stage dangles dangerously because of the
noise the laxative works and patrick's
fart turns pungent and loses its pitch
an embarrassed john stands humiliated as
the audience laughs moments later
placido gets on the stage and drags
patrick in front of everyone revealing
jon's secret
just then the spotlight falls on him
killing him instantly both john and
patrick are convinced of murder since
the falling of the spotlight was their
fault several people testify against the
poor kid saying that he has always been
cruel damon accuses him of trying to
kill him with his fart when the
reporters ask patrick about his thoughts
on the situation he claims that he was
with jon to look for his best friend and
didn't know that placido was going to
die allen from another country sees
patrick on tv and asks him to be brought
to the country as well back in the court
patrick is proven guilty of all charges
and is given the death penalty
right when he is about to be shot a
miracle happens a u.s special agent
comes to save him and legally brings him
to their headquarters he is also the
same person who had been spying on alan
and patrick for a long time patrick has
flown to america on a private jet upon
landing he reunites with allen who
claims that he was contacted by
astronaut ed shepherd the astronaut
recognized him as a genius kid and
recruited him to save the ones who are
stranded in space
since it was supposed to be a secret
allen couldn't tell patrick before
leaving he apologizes for being a bad
friend and the two reconcile patrick is
also told that only he who has two
stomachs can save the stranded
astronauts in space he is beyond happy
to finally get to be a spaceman they
meet ed shepherd who welcomes patrick to
their team following that allen
introduces patrick to his team of little
scientists recruited from around the
world they inform him of a device they
have created that will gather the energy
from his farts and multiply it using the
technique patrick will thus have to
launch the rescue rocket to space
starting that day he is trained to
become an astronaut the officials are
worried because he has failed all mental
and physical tests that an astronaut
should pass however ed shepard is
confident that the kid will rescue the
stranded team after a week of training
patrick is put in a spacesuit ready for
the mission the entire world watches in
awe as the kid boards the rocket however
allen is informed that there is a 70
chance that the rocket will blow up
shortly after liftoff he tells his
friend of the possibilities but patrick
doesn't back down on the count of 10 he
lets out a fart and the rocket lifts off
everyone in the control room cheers for
the kid but soon they lose all
communication as they begin to lose hope
the communication turns back on and
patrick finally reaches space in the
following scene we see him bring down
the stranded astronauts he is welcomed
with loud cheers and praised by everyone
in the world subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like thank you for watching